bonsoir à tous nous sommes le lundi 11
juillet vous regardez le 7 8 le journal
merci de nous retrouver pour cette
nouvelle édition comme chaque jour nous
revenons sur votre actualité locale
tweet on commence avec le sommaire
retour sur la finale de l'euro 2016 la
tristesse et la déception des supporters
français après cette finale remportée
par le portugal
le soutien des supporters n'aura pas
suffi nous avons vécu le match à vos
côtés à voisins le bretonneux et à
montigny le bretonneux et le jour de la
fête nationale approche à satory l'heure
est aux préparatifs 3200 soldats
s'entraîne pour la grande cérémonie du
14 juillet à versailles
nous avons suivi ses répétitions et
enfin que faire à cet été pour le
nouveau bachelier service civique
formation à l'étranger il faut déjà
penser à la prochaine rentrée
le point dans notre édition avec
laurence cousin directrice divine
information jeunesse et c'était la
désillusion la désillusion pour certains
et la célébration pour d'autres hier
soir la finale de l'euro 2016 qui
opposait la france au portugal a mis fin
au rêve bleu une équipe qui a fait rêver
son pays tout au long de la compétition
et qui assure rassembler son public ce
soit dans les fan zone ou dans les bars
les supporters français était présent
pour supporter les bleus patrick jacques
de dixmude était lui aussi sur place à
voisins mais aussi à montigny le
bretonneux pour prendre la température à
vos côtés retour sur le match on regarde
l'ambiance était pourtant là et les
supporters aussi oddateee à voisins le
bretonneux
le public était présent pour ce dernier
grand rendez vous de l'euro 2016 pour
cette finale qui opposait la france au
portugal on s'essaye même à certains
pronostics peut être un peu trop
optimistes trois pour la france 3 0
direct pas le temps pas le temps de
nantes 3-0 alors deux griezmann et un de
paillettes au coup sur coup franc 3 0
comme en 98 et 2 et 3 0 des buts qui ne
viendront pas pendant cette première
période plusieurs occasions côté
français et même une sortie sur blessure
de cristiano ronaldo star de cette
équipe portugaise
les équipes rentreront aux vestiaires
sur un score vierge qui égratigne
pourtant pas le moral des supporters un
peu déçu bien sûr que la panthère a
marqué on a concrétisé on n'a rien
concrétisé malheureusement mais ça va
venir se réveille toujours en seconde
mi-temps le genre taiseux artésien moi
j'y crois à montigny le bretonneux
ambiance cinéma le stade pierre de
coubertin transformé pour l'occasion en
fan zones locales les deux équipes iront
en prolongation jusqu'au but portugais
pour les spectateurs français c'est la
douche froide
c'est gratuit comme de monoï oui on
était persuadés qu'ils allaient le faire
mais dommage de passer à côté
déçu
et c'est tout ouah manque de chance
c'est tout très beau but très beau but
mais
on est français était pas là bravo aux
portugais on va rien dire d'autre
on donne rendez vous au port tudy et non
deux ans merci les bleus et on revient
sur le week end dernier avec les départs
en vacances sont 50000 véhicules étaient
attendus au péage de saint-arnoult temps
ni ville nous sommes allés dans les
coulisses de la gestion du trafic
autoroutier un reportage signé nicolas
landry il est 17 heures au péage de
saint-arnoult-en-yvelines jour de
départs des vacances d'été environ
soixante-dix mille véhicules sont
attendus pour ce vendredi 8 juillet et
au centre d'information trafic les
superviseurs veille sur la circulation
autoroutière
nous avons des informations qui sont
principalement relayés par nos
patrouilleurs qui circulent 24 heures
sur 24 sur notre réseau ces informations
la redescente vers les centres
d'exploitation qui rédige en fait des
fiches d'information vers le centre
d'information trafic avant que ça parte
sur la diffusion des panneaux messages
variables et de radio vinci autoroutes
sur ses écrans les vignettes
représentent les panneaux à messages
variables sur l'autoroute du grand ouest
je collecte les informations qui émanent
du réseau pour pouvoir après affichés
sur les panneaux et sergio arias blain
événements qui arrivent en direct j'ai
un bouchon sur nantes
donc voilà je permet de visualiser
qu'est-ce qui est qu'est ce qui se passe
à l'heure actuelle donc on a un bouchon
qui augmente en arrivant sur le
périphérique nantais localisation nombre
de véhicules concernés et causes de
l'incident
toutes ces informations sont envoyées
aux séité pour permettre d'évaluer les
conséquences sur le trafic
plusieurs types de dangers peuvent
intervenir c'est souvent soit des pertes
de chargement mal arrimé sur la route
soit des distances de sécurité du fait
du trafic qui est relativement dense qui
sont mal respecté des coups de frein
brutaux qui parfois occasionne pas
forcément des accidents très important
mais qui ont des conséquences en terme
de fluidité
relativement sensible au total près de 4
millions d'automobilistes devrait
emprunter le péage de
saint-arnoult-en-yvelines durant la
période estivale
vous l'avez vu les vacanciers sont déjà
partir sur les routes un peu partout les
contrôles se multiplient n'est pas
seulement sur les autoroutes ou encore
sur les péages à maurepas vendredi
dernier un dispositif de contrôle
avaient lieu pour rappeler les règles de
conduite est essentielle au conducteur
nous y étions regardez attention vous
excès de vitesse sur ce tronçon de
maurepas une étude réalisée en février
indique que sur une semaine plus de 800
véhicules dépasse la vitesse autorisée
c'est la raison de ce dispositif de
prévention une première pour la commune
nous avons des axes comme celui qui est
derrière moi venue de gastines où il ya
quatre mille véhicules par jour et dont
35% de deux de ces véhicules dépassent
largement les 50 km heure
l'idée c'est de sensibiliser le public
et d'avoir des actions aussi de
répression autour des équipements
publics et des écoles notamment à la
période de sorties scolaires
l'attestation science
cet automobiliste appréhender place de
bretagne ne roulait pas trop vite
elle a oublié de boucler sa ceinture et
s'en sort avec un simple rappel à
l'ordre
plus de peur que de mal non et voilà oui
mais ça c'est sûr que la ceinture elle
est obligatoire et il est bon de l'avoir
ceinture téléphone au volant et excès de
vitesse l'opération de prévention
réalisés par les neuf agents de la
police municipale avec de nouveaux
équipements comme un radar laser vie
surtout à sensibiliser les conducteurs
pour aujourd'hui oui on va rappeler
quelques consignes par rapport aux
distances de freinage au vitesse
réglementée que ce soit sur en
agglomération hors agglomération et
aussi par rapport à l'alcoolémie et les
dangers de la route que cela représente
ces opérations se poursuivront dès la
rentrée sur d'autres axes de la commune
concernée par ces vitesses excessives
il est temps à présent de passer à notre
entretien les vacances commence à peine
mais pour les étudiants il est déjà
temps de penser à la rentrée laurent ce
cousin directrice divine information
jeunesse nous a rejoint en plateau pour
nous donner quelques conseils bonsoir à
vous tous merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation alors premièrement est-ce
qu'il restait des démarches pour les
nouveaux bacheliers le 'process' russes
dont le processus d'inscription pour
l'année prochaine à faire alors il ya le
processus 1 ap b qui démarre
courant janvier donc que j'allais dire
bonne nouvelle pour ceux qui ont le bac
je dirais que tout est fait et voilà ils
sont sur les rails ils ont leurs voeux
donc normalement ils ont un
établissement qui les a choisis
il ya encore les affectations qu'ils
sont
en cours mais globalement c'est plus
pour ceux qui ont échoué au bac que se
posent des questions pour les parents et
pour les jeunes eux mêmes
donc ça c'est vrai que c'est un peu ça
peut gâcher entre guillemets les
vacances pour ceux qui sont qui vous
passer les épreuves du bac au rattrapage
et ce qui est des choses qu'ils doivent
faire attention
par rapport à la rentrée scolaire d'un
crochet bas le rattrapage c'est surtout
de focaliser parce qu'en général on
attend les résultats ne se prépare pas
forcément un rattrapage ou que le
conseil lui a peut-être un peu tard mais
ça veut dire de se préparer et à
l'éventuel rattrapage que l'on doit
avoir parce que mine de rien on mise
quand même là l'obtention de son
baccalauréat
ça c'est la première chose de bien se
préparer de ce day dont les conditions
pour pour avoir ces points manquants et
puis après c'est pareil ils ont ils ont
fait ils ont fait des voeux donc il ya
un dossier qui suit son cours moi le
conseil que je pourrais donner c'est
plutôt pour ceux qui sont là des motivés
qui n'ont pas eu leur baccalauréat
il ya eu un décret là qui est passé en
juillet 2015 qui permet sur l'art
préparation aux examens des voies
générales professionnelles et
technologiques
donc ça veut dire pour que ces jeunes
qui ont échoué au bac
ils peuvent bénéficier de plusieurs
dispositifs déjà de droit en fait ils
doivent solliciter leur établissement
scolaire actuel et ils sont prioritaires
pour être positionné redoublé dans leur
établissement actuel
ça c'est la première chose ensuite si
vous voulez c'est un projet qui va être
individuel avec chaque jeune donc il ya
dans cet établissement scolaire quand
ils sont pris un aménagement de l'emploi
du temps parce que bien sûr ils n'auront
pas toutes les épreuves aruba c'est un
don qu'ils ont deux mois en temps plein
au sein d'établissements scolaires et
après il ya un aménagement de leur
emploi du temps au sein de
l'établissement scolaire à 16 ans tout
l'année c'est il faut se renseigner ça
ça alors voilà le premier réflexe est de
contacter son établissement pour émettre
le souhait de redoubler dans cet
établissement de l'année d'après alors
d'ailleurs si vous nous faisons un point
sur l es bacheliers dans le département
les résultats au bac est l'heureux au
baccalauréat augmente légèrement cette
année 0,5 point à 87,3 % de reçus pour
le baccalauréat général
le nombre de bacheliers augmente
sensiblement de près de 800 lauréats
toutefois le taux de réussite s'élève à
voulue pour 102 présent soit une légère
baisse de 0,4 point le baccalauréat
technologique elle vit connaît une
hausse de 0.66 points et quant au
baccalauréat professionnel
l'augmentation est très sensible + 1 9
point à 77,5 % pour ceux qui justement
ont payé ou une baccalauréat les
nouveaux bacheliers
est-ce qu'il faut aussi s'intéresser
pour cet été par exemple le service
civique on fête son anniversaire à cette
année c'est quelque chose voilà qui peut
aider les étudiants ceux qui aiment arba
qui ne savent peut-être pas trop quoi
faire l'année prochaine alors dans
l'état d'esprit disons que le
volontariat en service civique c'est six
mois minimum
donc ça ne peut pas être un projet d'été
puisque là pour le coup un service
civique c'est un engagement sur 24
heures hebdomadaires donc s'il y
réfléchissent il faut que ce soit
compatible avec leur étude est de faire
ça à côté d'eux voilà ça peut être
compatible avec des études ça dépend du
niveau scolaire que l'on appliqué les
emplois du temps sont en fonction du
niveau du niveau scolaire donc donc à
réfléchir c'est vrai que des offres en
tant que volontaire il y en a beaucoup a
donc là l'idée c'est d'aller sur le site
du service civique
comme je disais donc c'est 6 8 mois ou
12 mois d'engagement auprès d'une
structure une collectivité une
association sur des thématiques
d'engagement c'est l'environnement la
santé la promotion des techniques
d'information et de communication enfin
y'a vraiment différent ce sujet
ces 24 heures minimum c'est quand même
ça représente quand même un engagement
important il faut savoir aussi que
l'indemnité puisqu'on parle pas de
salaire puisque ce n'est pas un emploi
on est bien sur du volontariat donc ça
doit pas se substituer à substituer ni à
un stage ni à un endroit pour une
structure qui l'accueille
c'est important de mentionner par contre
les indemnités d'art ont été valorisés
au 1er juillet donc l'indemnité d'un
jeune qui s'engage sur un service
civique
l'un des mythes est passé de 573 euros à
577 euros au 1er juillet et elle sera
valorisée à nouveau courant 2010 est
alors donc ça c'est quelque chose qui
peut être compatible avec des études
tactiques l'aja ça s'adresse à tout le
monde parce que il ya de plus en plus
d'offres notamment voilà sur notre
secteur à 50 en début ou les gens
recherchent donc des personnes pour
faire ce samedi
oui là on a eu la fève 78 ha qui
recherchent des services civiques et le
crous académie de versailles qui
recherchent également involontaire donc
c'est vrai que bazin de ces offres sont
bien sûr diffusée sur le site service
civique pour le move point fr
il faut excuser moi j'ai perdu le fil
info et c'est pour ces bons qui
s'adresse à tous alors il ya une tranche
d'âge en fait ça va juste donc ses 16 25
ans et ça va jusqu'à 30 ans pour les
personnes qui sont en situation de
handicap
donc il ya effectivement un âge d une
fausse et préparer là il ya des annonces
maintenant sera plus pour la rentrée si
on a envie de se lasser il y en a tout
au long de l'année en fait donc là il
n'y a pas de date précise c'est vrai que
l'été comme je disais ça pète un peu le
temps mort mais ça peut permettre de se
positionner serre que le jeune il doit
aussi savoir ce qu'il a envie de faire
et pour que ça fonctionne bien il faut
que l'équation se fasse bien entre la
structure d'accueil et le jeune et son
projet
c'est un temps de réflexion c'est une
preuve ça peut être une première
expérience professionnelle c'est un plus
pour le cv qu'est ce que c'est ah oui
c'est évidemment un plus une valeur
ajoutée sur le cv parce que on regarde
effectivement les les expériences
professionnelles mais aussi extra
scolaire parce qu'il ya des bons déjà ne
pas forcément beaucoup d'expérience
professionnelle et donc ça c'est vrai
que ça montre un profil intéressant de
jeunes engagés ça je pense que ça peut
être un crime motivé exactement pendant
l'été il est également conseillé
d'élargir son expérience et pourquoi pas
de voyager à l'étranger les aussi le
service civique en robien ce qui permet
aussi de voyager mais en même temps deux
soeurs service civique l'aed avoir plus
d'expérience exactement alors le service
civique est vrai que principalement
c'est en france mais c'est aussi à
l'international
donc il faut regarder et un moteur de
recherche multicritères donc ça peut
être aussi à l'international mais le s v
e
c'est vraiment spécifiquement un
partenariat avec les différents pays
européens et la france et donc les
jeunes partent forcément dans un pays
européen
vous conseillez vous les jeunes qui
souhaitent à partir à l'étranger pour
quelques mois pour approfondir leur
emblème l'heure espagnole à bas
complètement là on parlait de valeur
ajoutée sais tu vas entre guillemets une
double valeur ajoutée parce que souvent
c'est vrai que mon en france n'est pas
réputé pour bien maîtriser les langues
étrangères
et c'est vrai que le meilleur moyen
c'est d'être en immersion et d'avoir une
expérience dans un contexte
professionnel dans un pays européen
je crois que humainement et au niveau
linguistique ça peut être que positif et
les dispositifs va vers vous vous
conseiller
ça peut être sûr de moi là pour des gens
qui viennent d'avoir leur bac avant de
reprendre êtes seul alors c'est toujours
un peu compliqué parce que bon il ya un
coup de pouce financier aussi sur le s v
e est bon il faut il faut préparer un
dossier
donc pour ceux qui veulent partir cet
été le sv eux c'est un peu court est ce
que on se pose la question par rapport
au brésil donc la sortie du royaume uni
de l'union européenne est-ce que ça a
posé des soucis pour les jeunes qui
souhaitent partir en tête ceux qui sont
déjà en erasmus à la fac et qui sont au
royaume uni alors c'est vrai que bon
passé le choc de deux voilà du
référendum et du choix de la grande
bretagne de sortir de de l'union
européenne c'est vrai qu effectivement
ça c'est interroge les jeunes les
parents de dire est ce que je me
positionne sur un dispositif de mobilité
en grande-bretagne alors là j'ai envie
de dire que j'avais envie de dire pas de
panique parce qu'en fait le temps que ça
se mette en place cette sortie de la
grande-bretagne va se passer a minima
deux ans a pas de raison qu'on n'y a pas
d'enquêté
nous ce qu'on leur dit de toute façon
quand ils viennent nous voir et c'est
vrai que souvent ils veulent aller
notamment à londres parce que ça que
c'est très cosmopolite et c'est très
attractif
c'est que c'est une question d'offre et
de demande donc du coup c'est plus
compliqué pour un jeune même lionel
quelques années en arrière d'avoir une
proposition à londres même par exemple
donc on leur dit il ya d'autres pays
anglophones essayé de varier les voilà
les les choix de destinations pour avoir
le plus de chance de partir et pour ceux
qui veulent travailler également vous
occuper du bafa le bafa c'est toujours
une bonne chose pour la les étudiants ou
les bacheliers qui souhaitent enrichir
leur cv means faire un peu d'argent du
bafa c'est vrai que ça peut être un
choix alors au niveau de la mobilité
européenne ont fait des forum jobs d'été
mais plutôt alors là faut s'y prendre un
petit peu plus tôt on les fait en mars
avril et on a toujours aussi des offres
au niveau de l'europe et de
l'international
ça peut être aussi un premier premier
moyen de se faire en faire un peu
d'argent il partirait prochain
exactement le bafa alors le bafa bas il
faut être motivé par
par les fonctions d'animateur
socioculturel et sportif donc ça c'est
la première la première condition c'est
la motivation c'est vrai que le bafa
c'est d'encadrer des jeunes donc elle
souvent des jeunes mineurs
donc il ya quand même une vraie
responsabilité à voir donc il faut quand
même en avoir conscience quand on
s'engage mais c'est vrai que c'est un
tremplin pour avoir un job d'été c'est
il ya énormément de monde tout au long
de l'année et est principalement aussi
pendant l'été donc ça peut être un bon
moyen de se faire de l'argent de poche
pendant ces vacances scolaires tout en
afrique les colonies parfois n'attirait
plus autant qu'avant vous avez toujours
autant de demandes pour des animateurs
pour parce que ça alors le barça c'est
une demande récurrente de la part des
jeunes
d'ailleurs on met en place nous à peu
près quatre sessions bafa par an à des
tarifs attractifs pour pas que le coût
financier soit un frein aux jeunes qui
sont motivés et là il nous reste encore
quelques places offertes vite mais là on
démarre une une session bafa donc la
première cession obligatoire la la la
théorie le 16 juillet donc du 16 au 23
il ya une sessions bafa pour ceux qui
sont intéressés
il reste quelques places c'est en
externat en partenariat avec la mairie
de versailles et ça a lieu donc à la
maison de quartier près ou boire à
versailles un bien fou à être entendu si
cela vous intéresse n'hésitez pas à vous
rendre sur le site internet de lévis
d'information jeunesse vous retrouverez
tout cet incident informations merci
beaucoup aux laurence que nous avons sur
notre plateau d'avoir répondu à nos
questions
autre sujet à présent le jour de la fête
nationale approche à grands pas c'est
judy ce jour demande beaucoup de
préparation samedi à versailles l'heure
était aux répétitions pour le défilé du
14 juillet le camp de versailles satory
accueil l'armée qui s'entraîne pour le
jour j les troupes à pied regrouperont
plus de 3200 soldats cette année le
thème choisi et l'engagement un choix du
président de la république
regardez ce reportage signée manon labat
et michael almy deux roues le choix du
camp de versailles satory ne s'est pas
fait au hasard même étendue même largeur
le site est similaire à l'avenue des
champs-elysées les conditions sont
optimales pour l'entraînement de
l'ensemble des écoles militaires qui
participeront au défilé du 14 juillet
c'est la première journée ce sont leurs
premières répétitions s'est encore
nettement perfectible il nous reste
quatre jours pour obtenir la perfection
comme vous le savez le jour du 14
juillet ça sera parfait parfait les
officiers n'en doute pas une seconde
la rigueur est de mise les répétitions
se déroule sans accroc ça se passe bien
on le prépare beaucoup et en longuement
sur le long terme ne le prépare en fait
en permanence parce que c'est ça le rôle
du soldat c'est d'être toujours prêt à
remplir les missions qui vous seront
confiées
l'engagement c'est le thème de cette
année choisi par le président de la
république pour nous l'engagement c'est
vraiment ça représente le fait de
consacrer sa vie à protéger la nation
c'est faire honneur à la mission qui
nous est confiée
parce que pour nous c'est un honneur de
voir confier la mission de défendre les
intérêts de la france défilé le 14
juillet je ressens ça vraiment comme une
chance et un honneur après seulement
quatre mois de service d'autant plus que
c'est le premier 14 juillet après les
attentats du 13 novembre
donc je suis vraiment très fier et très
enthousiastes de participer au 14 juin
3235 soldats défileront à pied jeudi
accompagné de 210 véhicules
deux cent quarante cavaliers de la garde
républicaine 55 avions et 30
hélicoptères répétition générale mardi
avec ce conseil pour les débutants
donner le meilleur d'eux-mêmes et puis
qu'on arrive à travers à voir à travers
leur manière de défilés de voir leur
fierté et leur professionnalisme et cap
à présent sur magny les hameaux la 7e
édition de remets tes tongs s'est
ouverte mardi dernier à proximité de
l'estaminet pour cette programmation
2016 les organisateurs ont misé sur les
légumes
une vingtaine de stands ont été dressés
pour répondre à ce cahier des charges
végétarien un reportage signé le
week-end et demi d'euros
un parfum d'été à magny les hameaux la
7e édition de remets tes tongs s'est
ouverte mardi 5 juillet d'air
l'estaminet une vingtaine d'animations
gratuites et ouvertes aux petits et aux
grands jusqu'au 14 juillet cette année
la programmation tourne autour des
légumes
donc on trouve tout un tas d'ateliers on
a décliné le thème donc avec des
ateliers de musique sur les gunnes de
sculpture sur légumes des ateliers
jardin bricolage plantations on a aussi
tout un tas d'animations sportives
malles pleines découvert que a toujours
des nouveautés chaque année de nouveaux
outils si j'avais eu même nom jeu tout
simple c'est très sympa de plus en plus
il faut faire profiter encore nos
enfants des fruits et légumes et leur
faire partager le bon goût
et des fruits sains particulièrement
dans cette programmation 2016
végétarienne on retrouve un stand de
sculptures un peu particulier ici les
carottes les poireaux les oranges et les
pommes de terre sont tranchées cisaillé
entaillé assemblée pour ressembler à des
personnages les cours sont
principalement destinés aux enfants sont
très créatifs en plus ses fils leur
donner deux trois idées leur montrer
comment on fait un oeil comme en fait
une aile
comment on fait des cheveux et après eux
ils le font tout seuls c'est partir en
général après les parents sont venus me
disant ils ont tout pris les légumes qui
intrigue au ce côté l'animation légumes
devrait attirer entre 300 et 400
personnes par jour sont les
organisateurs un avant goût d'été qui
donnerait presque envie à certains de
rester cet été à manille l'amour du
soleil est toujours à magny les hameaux
vous l'avez sans doute aperçu si vous
vous êtes arrêté près de l'hôtel de
ville un arc de triomphe de 4 mètres de
haut a été installé sur le parvis
mercredi dernier la structure fabriquée
à l'occasion de la 100e édition de
l'open de france de golf organisé début
juillet au golf national de saint
quentin en yvelines a été offerte à
magny les hameaux après la compétition
écoutez la réaction des habitants je
dirais que ça fait plutôt pas mal ça ça
remplit ça remplit l'espace
donc ça simplement de bien je pense dans
le niveau des trottoirs tout ça sur
l'espace avec le public autour donc je
pensais pas trop mal je dirais que ça
fait un peu un mouvement un une
animation
après le vin artistique je dirais que
ouais on peut être
pour ou contre mais ouais ça fait c'est
sacré quelque chose de positif et ça
amènera certainement quelque chose à mes
amani vermont et on revient sur du sport
la 14e étape de la coupe de france de
foot de golf un sport hybride était
organisée ce week-end au golf de
l'actuelle les yvelines coup de
projecteur sur cette nouvelle discipline
qui compte près de 3000 licenciés dont
l'hexagone un reportage signé michael
est le héros et patrick jacques de
dixmude heures ce dimanche 10 juillet
les golfeurs ont troqué leur club contre
les crampons et un ballon au golf des
yvelines la 14e étape de la coupe de
france de foot golf était d'organiser
sur les greens de structures comme son
nom l'indiqué ce sport mélange les deux
disciplines
on joue vraiment avec les règles du golf
mais avec les outils du football c'est à
dire qu'en fait vous avez un ballon de
foot taille 5 un ballon pines standard
on va dire et le pied mais par contre
vous je vais vraiment sur les règles du
golf avec toutes les difficultés que
présente le parcours de golf les bunkers
les plans d'eau les greens
créée en 2009 aux pays bas ce sport est
pratiqué aujourd'hui dans 45 pays qui
compte près de 3000 licenciés une
vingtaine de clubs en france des
compétitions nationales européennes et
mondiales sont organisées chaque année
une compétition par équipe de deux
l'après midi c'est le schéma classique
de la football cup
toutes nos étapes sont sur le même
schéma avec les deux formats de
compétition pour pratiquer cette
discipline tenue correcte exigée les
joueurs doivent s'habiller de façon
élégante avec des chaussettes hautes et
avec des crampons stabilisés et pour
être un bon football for iphone plus du
style avoir quelques qualités techniques
il faut doser
il faut cibler il faut assurer donc
c'est un vrai sport technique c'est un
vrai sport mental aussi
ça nous arrive aussi de passer à travers
un trou de qui nous coûte un podium par
exemple ja demandent des qualités de
footballeur ça c'est indéniable il faut
quand même être bon footballeur
celui qui a jamais joué au foot ça ça va
être compliqué quand même et après
beaucoup de concentration pour marquer
de beaucoup le foot golf peut se
pratiquer sur 32 parcours de golf en
france dans les yvelines château propose
un terrain avec neuf trous un
partenariat est également envisagée avec
le golf national de saint quentin en
yvelines dans les prochaines années
c'est à présent la fin de cette édition
je vous remercie de nous avoir suivis
mais restez avec nous dans quelques
instants
vous retrouvez le cfid sport présentée
par michael et demi d'euros profitez-en
ce sera le dernier de la saison quant à
moi je vous retrouve demain pour un
nouveau numéro du journal je vous
souhaite une excellente soirée